hallo mein name ist meine liebste wollte
ich dann heute endlich mal wieder recht
herzlich willkommen heißen seiner
trainer die sonne auf die mit ca
allerdings wäre ich natürlich nicht ich
werde ich nicht ich wäre und einfach
ganz normal auf die leute jetzt hier auf
irgendwie treffen würde denn ich habe
mir das hier überlegt also die sehen
mich so
ich habe mich gleich auf die treffe ich
bin gespannt ob mich jemand erkennt denn
ich werde selbstverständlich erst mal
nicht reden
ich sehe ein bisschen aus wie ein fisch
[Musik]
ich wusste echt ernst bei bleiben
deine augen
[Musik]
oha
die augen
[Musik]
gabi gerne augen sind noch mal
in diesem heft sehe ich die augen
ich muss mal wirklich
wir machen es jetzt einfach so dass wenn
die leute mich nicht direkt kippen nach
ein paar sekunden sondern wirklich mit
mir reden und dran bleiben dann fange
ich auch an zu reden
[Musik]
schöne augen
aber er halte ich auch schon zwei
komplimenten wir beide augen bekommen
nimmt man die geschneidert und sie dann
damit
apropos rudi allerdings wo gibt's denn
eigentlich ist der lg zutiefst geehrt
holte
hallo augen so hast du bist aber eine
angenehme auch einfach nicht nicht
herzlich superschicke habt ihr auch
augen weil praktisch damit kann man
sehen echt ja nur dich also ich bin der
mensch mit den augen ich verstehe ja ja
ich mal kommt braucht sicherheit und
benannt stimmt peter kuka was macht ja
ja ich kann euch zeigen das innsbrucker
bin hier hallo
was gelernt habt ihr schönes
[Musik]
und jetzt haben nämlich einfach
weggedrückt ich muss das auch meistens
dann bei dates von mir
man schreibt über instagram und dann
sehen nämlich dann in echt weltfrieden
oder nie direkt ab irgendwie
[Musik]
ich glaube will komplimenten augen
ja
ich mache das weil ich komme nie mehr
für meine augen haben wir ja ich hab mir
gedacht ich meine stellt euch mal vor da
liegt ein typ mit seiner freundin im
bett macht die gegend wie beim fernseher
angeschlossen oder beamer keine ahnung
was das auf einmal ist ein typ wirklich
so und guckt ich so an als würde direkt
aus dem bett zu bringen
[Musik]
nein warum
das verbot dann kommt man in die hölle
der frage
durch den witz erzählen ja
[Musik]
kanada kann
ja meinten dass ich ihn hits leute hmm
er weiß dass ich immer hin wollte
ja ich habe nicht gefragt und du weißt
warum ich mit
hey
das habe ich gar nicht verstanden ich
habe ihn gefragt wie zum witz hören er
sagt ja ich sage okay mir fällt keine
einhell warum woher weißt du dass ich
ein witz hören wollte
[Musik]
muss die kamera
für die nase
da habe ich auf dem tisch ich habe keine
ahnung ob das ganze jetzt zum anschauen
genauso lustig ist wie es für mich
gerade ist aber es ist so witzig wenn
diese leute einfach mitmachen
ok heikos aber schöne augen und so eine
reine haut
basel so klappt
das ist nichts für mich
das ist nichts für mich ist schon
peinlich weil mich auf der straße leute
erkennen die solchen dass ihr handeln
sich zusammen
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich hat braune augen nicht
grün rötlichen vor allem käse fresse
gerade günstige ziegenkäse auf
frankreich in frankreich warnte jetzt
eine beseitige video für das
sprachenlernen
das war doch ein schönes video fürs
heutige video meine lieben freunde wenn
euch das heutige video gefallen hat dann
das gerne einen daumen hoch und ein
video er da schreibt mir gern und in die
kommentare was ich mir im nächsten raum
sowie video machen sondern abonniert
main kanal wenn ihr das nicht verpassen
wollte und dieser rudi den gibt
[Musik]